les phrases sont remplies de vitamines a
et c d'antioxydants et de résidus de
pesticides en 2016
95 % des échantillons de ces petits
fruits rouges cultivés aux états unis
contenaient des traces de pesticides du
lot 5 % dépassé les limites permises
mais le québec fait il mieux le
ministère de l'agriculture nous a donné
accès aux résultats des analyses
d'échantillons de fraises du québec
effectué entre 2007 et 2016
80 % des échantillons contenaient les
résidus d'au moins un pesticide
alors que 17% contenait les traces de
plus de 5 pc side la limite maximale de
résidus n'était toutefois dépassé que
dans un seul cas nous avons transmis ces
informations à un expert
même si on respecte les niveaux de
risque
on peut observer notamment que yo
certains de ses produits qui ont des
effets toxiques potentiel 14 pesticides
dont on a retrouvé des traces sur les
fraises sont des cancérigènes possibles
ou probables
l'association des producteurs de fraises
et framboises du québec fait valoir que
les résidus de pesticides sur les
aliments sont deux cent à trois mille
fois inférieure aux limites établies par
santé canada
est ce qu'il ya une place ou un résidu
dommageable
saad aygalades au site c'est à eux qu'on
fait confiance pour leur santé malgré
tout les scientifiques conseillent de
continuer de manger des fruits et
légumes pour les bienfaits nutritionnels
associés à leur consommation mais il
faut absolument les laver à l'eau
courante pour éliminer le plus de traces
de pesticides
une pratique qui ne fait disparaître
qu'une partie des résidus seulement ici
julie vaillancourt radio canada montréal